Chana Kanzen,
thank you so much for joining me.
How are you?
I'm very well, thank you.
I know you're extremely extremely busy.
So, thank you for taking the time
to do this.
You're the CEO of Jewish Interactive,
a non-profit organization,
very successful non-profit organization.
But you're an educator at heart.
A teacher by profession.
And you have your own views on education
and what needs to happen
in order to improve education
and spread messages to children
around the world.
Right now, you're focusing
on Jewish education,
but you're passionate about
the broader sense of education
and how to do that more effectively.
So, I'd love to hear a little bit
about your journey.
We'll start from there.
And we'll talk also, obviously,
about Jewish Interactive
and what you're doing over there.
Sure. So, I've been a teacher
for about 20 years.
Started teaching every age group
from little ones right through
to high school.
And I've always been really passionate
about good education
and getting the kids excited.
And I feel it's a really important role.
And about 10 years ago,
I was actually leading a school.
I was approached
by the current chief rabbi actually
in the UK to open up a school.
So, I like challenges.
And I decided,
okay, I'll open up a school.
But I wanted it to be a beacon school.
I wanted it to be a school
that would be a model for other,
especially Jewish schools to look at.
And we worked really hard.
By the way, just for context,
when you're saying
you're a teacher for 20 years,
is this specifically Jewish education
or what sort of teaching did you do?
No. I was a qualified teacher
to general studies.
And about halfway through my career,
I actually started to work
in Jewish schools and realized that,
actually, anywhere up to 50% of the day
in a Jewish school
is devoted to Jewish education.
But what I found fascinating
was the delivery and actual relevancy
of the education for that 50% or 20%
or 10% was just not very good.
The teachers weren't always qualified
or they didn't have good resources.
And I found that quite disturbing,
actually, that parents are choosing
to send their kids to a school
for that reason.
And yet the education
that was being delivered
was not on the same standard.
So, I decided to move
being a qualified teacher
into the Jewish faith
to try and up the game.
And so, we opened up this Jewish school,
the beacon school
and it was very exciting.
And this was 10 years ago,
more actually, about 13 years ago.
We started opening a school
and smart boards were just coming in.
And it's amazing how much things
have moved in the past 13 years.
But if you think back,
we didn't even have iPhones then.
It was like really computers.
Were just coming into school
and it was just the beginning
of the technology boom.
It was the Facebook.
I remember those smart boards,
I remember them coming in
and slowly being placed
in the classrooms. Right.
Right.
So, because we're new school,
we had smart boards in every classroom.
It's really cool.
And I had great stuff to put on it
for math and English,
and it came to Jewish studies.
And it just really wasn't anything
except for some Chabad videos.
And I was just thinking,
this is crazy.
Like there's just no good content
for religious education.
And in parallel,
what's going on is that
you've got the world is just going crazy.
And religious education is really about
mainly morals and inclusivity
and living good lives.
So, as people
most general religions like that.
And yet, the way it was being delivered,
it was in a very old fashioned
paper-based worksheets.
So, these kids were experiencing
English and math in this
really virtual exciting way.
And then the religious education
was very 2D.
And that, for me was a really big problem.
And I met this girl
who came from South Africa,
her name was Nikki Neufeld.
And she had this CD
that she had made about Shabbat.
And she put it in my computer
and it was like Disney animation,
blew my mind.
I haven't seen anything like this before
and it's just like,
"Where have you been all my life?"
"This is exactly what I need."
I can't even imagine.
Disney animation is about Shabbat.
Yeah, it was like
this whole animated Disney style.
Amazing CD and the amazing story
was that she had created this,
she wasn't an educator,
but she had created the CD
on bedrest throughout her pregnancy.
She couldn't get up
and she had this idea
to create digital content
and she made this CD.
So, she came.
And I didn't even watch it.
Like she put it in my computer
within first seconds,
I was like, "I love it."
She's like, "But wait, see the rest of it."
"I don't need to see anymore."
"I want my school to use this."
"This is what we need."
"But why isn't it online?"
"And where is your educational guide?"
"And where's your lesson plans?"
And I was just grilling her
and she was like,
"Okay. Okay, I need you
to come and work with me."
And at that point,
I have been in education,
formal education all my life,
salary jobs, I was training and lecturing
and doing all sorts of things.
But I never thought
about leaving the security of a salary
and starting something,
especially a non-profit.
I had no non-profit background at all.
It was a funny story, actually.
I remember I went to see a funder
to potentially get office space
for Jewish Interactive.
And she said to me,
"So, have you got a boards?"
And I said,
"So, what's a board?"
That's how green I was.
Like, I literally did not know anything
about what I was doing.
I just knew I had this vision.
I knew that this is something
that needs to be done.
So, I have to say already kind of that,
a lot of people
that are coming on this in the series
are the entrepreneurs, investors,
a lot of them coming from the tech scene.
And over there, going to the tech scene,
the route is pretty known that
when find the pain point,
you raise money, you go build a startup.
Now you're coming in,
which I think is fascinating
as 20 years into education
and you're saying that,
Okay. While I'm teaching general studies,
I'm seeing that there is this gap
and the way that Jewish education,
it doesn't necessarily have to be Jewish,
but in general, there is a gap
that a certain segment of education
is not receiving, is not getting
the quality education that it needs.
There's this gap.
I'm going to create a school
that is going to do this better.
And then you find somebody
who is actually leveraging technology
to actually make this
much more interactive.
I just think that it's fascinating
to draw the parallel because this is
pure entrepreneurship right there.
It really was.
I mean, she basically
was almost like an investor.
So, she had this trust fund set up
that she wanted to devote
to developing this.
But she didn't have the mechanism.
She wanted to pilot it in England
because it was a small community.
And I happened to be quite good networker
and I was networked with all the schools.
So, we just gathered or I gathered.
I got in contact with all the principals
and we did this release and we did this,
we just released the product
without even having a company.
So, basically what we did was
we had this whole day
and 70 teachers turned up.
It was unheard of.
Like 70 school appeared
and by the end of the day,
they were signing checks
to Jewish Interactive, which didn't exist.
So, I walked away
with like $6,000 in checks and no company.
Wait. So, were they trying
to purchase the product or donations?
Yeah. So, we are almost like
a social enterprise.
So, what we do is we believe
in charging for some of our products
because we want to bring in revenue,
sustainable revenue,
but not to make a profit.
Any revenue that we bring in
goes to the non profit.
And also, because the Jewish market
is quite small, it's not sustainable.
So, most technology,
the way that they work is scalability
and mass consumption.
But even if we reached
every single Jewish child in the world,
it wouldn't really be profitable.
So, we need to tap
that non-profit element into it.
But at the same time,
this was at the beginning
of the technology boom,
which was having an impact on education.
So, I left my job
and I started Jewish interactive.
But at the same time,
I was advocating
for different approaches in education
because what I could see is
I saw something remarkable happen.
I walked into my classroom of 30 kids
with an iPad and it wasn't even open,
and it was like bees to honey.
Like all of a sudden
I had 30 kids around this iPad
with this engagement
that I had never seen before
with anything else that I did.
And if you are a passionate teacher
and you want to get something across,
then you're going to use
the most effective way of doing them.
For me, I could see that the levels
of concentration and engagement
on these devices was just unprecedented.
I hadn't seen that before and I thought,
"Whatever happens,
I have to get my head around this.
If I want to get to these kids."
Because this is where they're at.
And the issue that I then had
was years of trying to convince
head teachers and teachers
that we've got to move this.
It's not even debatable.
It's not a luxury.
So, they perceived technology
as this luxury.
And even today, you go into classrooms
and many classrooms are still paper-based.
The kids are writing,
handing in their results.
They don't get their results
'till two weeks later.
And how does that correlate
with these kids' day to day experience
of instant gratification.
There are multiple platforms
that accessing huge levels of information
and yet the teaching,
the education methods have not moved on.
So, what's happening are
a lot of teachers who haven't moved on
are still focused
on delivering content and information,
which is just not where,
the kids don't need to know
and be delivered huge amounts
of information any more on rote learning.
What they need to do
is learn how to access
the right information.
They need to learn how to collaborate,
how to access and build relationships,
emotional intelligence,
all of these other skills
that are so vital for jobs today
are not being taught.
So, what I did, I actually made
some connections with Google and Apple
and we started to train.
We actually had a couple of trainings
in Apple headquarters in London
for all the Jewish teachers in the UK.
And Google helped as well
to try and train these teachers
in embedding technology
into their classroom.
And it's not just about having a computer.
We can see that now
with covid really quickly.
Really, it's being actually
fascinating for me
to watch over the past six months
what's happened.
Because what's happened
in the past six months,
I've been advocating for years.
And all of a sudden education has moved,
I would say, more in the past six months
than it has in the past 20 years.
It's unbelievable how, now,
every single teacher
has had experience
with online education,
whether they like it or not.
Some have been really successful
and some have been really frustrated
and some children
have been really successful,
have been really frustrated.
And I think that it's not about,
it's not the technology
that's the problem,
it's you cannot teach online
in the same way
that you've been teaching offline.
You have to change the pedagogy.
And so, that's what
I've been trying to do is
to change people's approach to education.
And instead of
just delivering information,
changing that whole emphasis
unto allowing children
to access knowledge and learn
and be self directed and creative,
which you know, and I suppose
most people watching here
who are entrepreneurs know that
these are essential skills
for entrepreneurship which we know.
Or any learner in the 21st century, really.
Yeah. And quite frankly,
with this new generation that's coming up,
like these kids,
they're going to be graduating
in what? 2025, 2030, right?
Where is the world going to be that,
how many jobs are going to be available.
If these kids
don't have the skills to be creative
and to work in a global way
and collaborate,
they're not going to be employable.
Because all the other jobs
aren't going to exist, right?
The jobs that the teachers
are currently teaching for
will not be there.
So, unless they have experience
in these skills, they're just not going
to be able to survive in the world.
And school is meant to be
priming your children for survival
in the world.
And it's not being doing that
up till now.
I think what's happened with covid is that
the world is sort of,
especially the world of education
is having to rethink.
It's being forced to rethink.
And it's difficult and it's challenging
and not everyone's getting it right.
But it's necessary.
And it's been a really interesting
few months to observe this
going on in the world
and seeing what's working, what isn't.
And I think we've definitely hit
a turning point.
I don't think there's any going back.
I think that technology and education
is here to stay and we've just got to
get our heads around that
and make it work.
And what been great for me is that
I've been privileged to be in a position
for the past 10 years
where I've been gradually working
with a bigger and bigger market.
I now work with a global market,
with schools all around the world.
And so, I'm able to see
what works and what doesn't
and how they're using platforms.
And we're now actually building
a new platform,
not just for the Jewish world,
for everybody.
We're building an open source platform
so anybody can use it.
And the idea of this platform is
for teachers to create content
and children to learn asynchronously
using this content
and build the sharing community.
And so, we're developing this now.
It's really exciting.
And it's really a gift
to be able to develop this platform
during the time of covid
when we've got so many teachers
who are experiencing
challenges and blockages.
And we're trying to get that information
and then build that into
what we're creating.
So, it's a very exciting time for us
at the moment.
Of course. But Chana, then I have to ask
so, everything that we've talked about
until now, it sounds like it's relevant
for all subjects in education
and for all teachers and for all students.
Why is it Jewish Interactive?
Because it sounds like
even that experience of having that person
come in with a CD
and and sharing those lessons
about Shabbat in an interactive way,
it sounds like the pain point
and the solutions you uncovered
is something that's relevant
for many many other fields, right?
So, why specifically in that market?
Because you're starting off
by also saying that,
inherently the Jewish education market
is so small that you have to position this
as an NGO.
Why not take this to a for profit company
that is trying to help education
all around?
It's a really good question.
There's a few reasons for that.
First of all,
the Jewish market needs specific content.
And what's very difficult
about the Jewish market is
there's a saying that:
if you have two Jews,
you have three opinions.
Right?
So, the same with all the schools.
Every school is unique.
So, everyone says,
"Why don't you just do
like one curriculum on Judaism
and then you've got it."
And there's been many many people
that have made online curriculums
about Judaism.
So, why do we need to do it?
And the answer is that
every school has their unique,
their USP so to speak,
and every school has their own way
of delivering that form of education.
And that's what makes this school unique
and that's why people
sending their kids at school.
So, what we did was
we developed a platform
that allows people
to create their own content
that's personalized to them.
Now that is relevant to everybody.
You're right.
But someone needed to do it
for the Jewish market.
And because it wasn't profitable,
who's going to do that?
If you want to start a business
and make it profitable,
you're not going to do something
for the Jewish market.
But unless we actually consciously did it,
there wouldn't be anyone doing that.
So, I had a decision to make,
I could either build
a profitable business.
If I wanted to build
a profitable business, I would have to
not focus on the Jewish content
to make it profitable.
And I just decided
that I didn't want to do that.
I wanted to give
to the Jewish world consciously.
And in order to do that,
I had to make a non-profit.
I wasn't going to make profit.
And what's actually amazing
about this organization is we have
the most phenomenally talented people
that I've cultivated and brought together
amazing amazing team members.
And they all feel the same way.
They're all doing this
out of a social conscious need
for the Jewish world.
And they're very talented.
All of them could work
in like Google or Facebook.
But they're doing it because they feel
there is a need for the Jewish world.
So, if you look at other markets
like the Islamic market
and the Christian market,
there are phenomenal phenomenal products.
They have much bigger budgets.
They have much more people for a start.
And they have phenomenal content
And the Jewish world just doesn't.
So, I mean, there are other organizations
that are doing great jobs
for high school and beyond.
But there wasn't really
anyone doing something
for the elementary and middle school,
and we felt that that was needed.
So, it was a conscious decision
to actually be a nonprofit
to fill a need in the Jewish market.
However, you're right.
What we are building now,
the place that we've got to now,
where we're actually building
our own platform,
is consciously being built
for other markets,
not just the Jewish market.
We've taken our learning
because we're quite way a small community.
There's only 5,000 Jewish schools
in the world and we're working
with about a thousand of them already.
Really?
Yeah.
Wow. 20% of the market you're going after.
We do.
And in over one hundred countries
so we can really see
the cultural differences
and what's happening.
We've got a global view
of what's happening in education.
So, we can take that information
to develop this platform
and then share it beyond
the Jewish market.
And at that point, it is possible
that we could diversify
and form a for profit
that will help the non-profit market.
But if we wouldn't have focused
on the Jewish market,
then that would still be the spark here
because it isn't profitable.
So, it's like a labor of love
at the moment.
It's something that I wanted to give
to the Jewish world.
And it's not just me.
I wouldn't be where I am today
without a phenomenal team,
phenomenally talented team
who are based in four countries.
And an amazing board
and phenomenal founders
and visionaries who will come together
to do this thing.
So, it's very exciting. Yeah.
That's just unbelievable.
Chana, 20 minutes go by way too fast.
But this is just inspiring.
Incredible, you're in 100 countries.
You're in a thousand schools.
You're in 20% of the Jewish schools.
I mean, that's it.
And the whole story
is just so entrepreneurial.
It's like raw entrepreneurship.
It's just that it's very very inspiring.
And I wish you best of luck.
Thank you for being so generous
with your time. Before we finish,
I have to ask you
the most important question,
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
Three words I would use
to describe myself.
So, I think, I have to say an educator.
Because I'm passionate about education.
I'll use three words in one word,
like pushing the boundaries.
I like to push.
And resilient. I'm very resilient.
Which you have to be running a nonprofit,
especially in the Jewish world.
And I think to be a teacher,
you have to be resilient to open a school.
You have to be resilient
into run a nonprofit, let alone a company,
you have to be resilient.
Chana, thank you very very much.
Consider doing good for the world.
And stay safe and stay healthy.
My pleasure.
Take care
Thank you.